quand je regarde un homme la première
chose que je regarde c'est sa femme non
parce que ça a changé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai envie d'écrire des mots parce que
vous avez très longtemps que ça ne
travaillait un petit peu je l'ai pas
fait toute seule parce que j'avais un
partenaire qui est un grand smatcher et
on se fait une bonne partie de ping-pong
tous les deux voilà évidemment avec des
jeux de mots mais en essayant de par
exemple de sortir de phrases
idiotes comme il faut souffrir pour être
belge je trouve tout souffrir vous moi
je dis il faut souffrir
ça peut faire rire le titre mais enfin
c'est l'histoire d'un SDF et puis il y a
la traversée du désir en fait alors
c'est un album sans artifice très très
rare comme ça votre votre voix un peu
cassée
c'est arrondi moi aussi d'ailleurs un
bon c'est tout s'arrondit et puis je
crois que c'est c'est un album mon
sérénité c'est peut-être pas j'ai pas
acheté non plus une auréole à la
Saint-Marc mais je je dirais que
aujourd'hui je me sens bien dans ma peau
et j'avais pas besoin d'être bien dans
ma peau pour écrire des chansons très
tristes parce que je lis plus facile
d'aller gratter les Bleus qu'on a au
fond de l'âme quand on est bien dans sa
peau voilà plein de projets plein de
choses
du Graal voilà une adaptation scénique
de l'album éponyme alors c'est
l'histoire de Merlin l'enchanteur
Lancelot Guenièvre etc à Montréal en
2006 en fait il y a plus aucune comédie
musicale qui marche en France il faut
dire quand même
fatigué donc on va aller voir ailleurs
ce qui se passe et puis on viendra ici
vous avez déjà eu quand même des gros
échecs revus et corrigés de avec Bob de
coups et Annie Girardot c'est un gros
échec il y avait pas grand monde mais
bon c'était la première fois on était
les un peu les pionniers dans l'histoire
c'était pas encore tout à fait instauré
et puis les romantiques moi j'avais les
goûts de grandeur il y avait 50
musiciens sur scène parce que je voulais
pas de bande et au bout de 10 jours
évidemment le budget était un peu mais
je l'ai fait c'était beau le Châtelet
était plein et on a vécu un instant
merveilleux
formidable c'est qu'après ces deux gros
échecs et malgré l'un succès de beaucoup
de comédies musicales en France vous
ayez quand même envie de monter Graal
bah oui mais on vient de faire 100000
albums c'est pas si mal disque d'or et
les romantiques qu'on avait fait aussi
150 000 albums c'est pas des échecs
cuisants c'était le début il faut le
temps c'est un état d'esprit qui est pas
tout à fait encore instauré en France
quoi alors Catherine vous avez commencé
votre carrière en accompagnant Mireille
Mathieu Nana Mouskouri Juliette Gréco
est-ce que c'est ces femmes qui vous ont
donné envie d'aimer les femmes non non
j'aime les êtres et puis ça vient de
toute petite j'ai toujours aimé je suis
attiré par les belles personnes voilà
sans distinction alors j'ai reçu un coup
de téléphone cet après-midi de votre
attaché de presse qui m'a dit Thierry ne
lui dis pas tu as cette phrase qu'on
vous répète à chaque fois et je vous de
toute façon je l'aurais pas fait mais
quand je regarde un homme la première
chose que je regarde c'est sa femme et
non
[Rires]
on m'a appelé pour me dire de pas vous
poser la question bon ben tout va bien
je l'ai dit et puis tu es plutôt drôle à
l'époque je vous pose pas la question
mais non mais tout va bien quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me bagarre pas tellement ça vous
tente un petit bras de ferrade
[Rires]
Catherine Lara est un vrai garçon manqué
Catherine est-ce que vous savez changer
la roue d'une voiture oui
est-ce que c'est siffler avec vos doigts
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous arrive de boire une
bière en regardant un match de l'équipe
de France de football Maryse de boring
bière en regardant pas mal de choses
mais oui éventuellement est-ce que vous
mettez le réveil le dimanche matin pour
regarder le téléphone
est-ce que vous êtes forte en créneau
oui
vous regardez quoi en premier chez une
fille
c'est plutôt l'humour qui m'attire
plusieurs profité qu'une fille soit
bourrée pour coucher avec non jamais non
plus sympathique ça vous énerve quand
votre copine passe des heures à se
préparer oui
c'est vous surprend qu'une fille n'est
pas envie de faire l'amour parce qu'elle
a la migraine
j'ai pas vraiment connu ça
j'ai déjà trompé votre copine en disant
c'est juste pour le sexe ah bah oui
vous quitteriez une fille parce qu'elle
est nulle au lit
j'ai pas à regarder sur les femmes
je suis une femme et j'ai un regard de
femme sur les êtres en général mais
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça serait bien la carte fellation
vous gagnez une non laissez tomber c'est
pas une
fausse carte en fait c'est une fausse on
recommence mais elle était bien c'est
dommage
[Musique]
vous devez dire du mal de se serait
manuel en franchement c'est pas possible
ça ah si c'est bien ça
parce que cette conne
je me sens incapable de faire ça j'ai un
tel respect pour cette femme ah non dire
du mal de se réveiller
sa cornette lui va pas bien
du mal c'est impossible de dire du mal
une femme aussi parfaite tu sais ce que
c'est quand on fait on peut pas faire la
carte on doit embrasser quelqu'un
bon alors Olga
es-tu là la fille tout à l'heure
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que tout à l'heure
[Musique]
Catherine
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu